now to be honest i i just did it
probably like three weeks ago so
everybody i've been kind of black
who the [ __ ] is the biggest [ __ ] like
who the [ __ ] is the bigger crib and i'm
like
yeah you know it's me so
how is the crypt culture different in
memphis you think
than it is over here because we're in la
you know this is the birthplace of this
[ __ ] oh see like the other thing that's
really different is it's a lot of
politics out here in memphis
it's like you got
grape street you got bounty hunters
riding with graves creeks in memphis
it's like but i heard they they rivals i
mean they don't [ __ ] with each other at
all but just that [ __ ] it's like that
would never happen out here yeah no out
here that's but in memphis you got [ __ ]
it ain't about to click cause you got
[ __ ] there's there's grave street
bounty hunter but they they could cause
they blood cousins so they're gonna ride
with their blood for anything before the
yeah
out here it's this is not the case
because it's just too deep it's too deep